hello everyone today we are playing a
memoir blue which is an annapurna uh
title that i'm playing on game pass i
thought this game looked really lovely
for a really long time the team at
annapurna gave me a code very big thank
you to them
um
but i did want to say before we start
this video just a disclosure i don't
normally have to give
it's very likely that i will finish this
game
throughout this video um i do these
hour-long gameplay recordings and i'd be
surprised if this takes more than an
hour for me to finish
with games like this
let's players can really take away the
uh experience for other players so if
you have any interest in playing
it's based on this screen or whatever
you've heard about it please go play it
instead
or
if you
liked this video and you enjoyed
watching the game i will leave a link in
the description to where you can check
out more about studio maybe follow them
on twitter um maybe buy the game
yourself because you still got an
experience out of it um
obviously again they gave me the code
meaning they want me to make content out
of it but at the same time
i just wanted to make sure i'm doing my
due diligence to not take
sales away from the studio who made it
so
let's jump into it shall we
i don't know fully what to expect other
than i thought that this game looked
really lovely from everything i've seen
of it
i didn't expect to start there
and yeah i just looks like it has like
very nice art and really nice music and
a nice little indie experience is what
i'm expecting here
[Applause]
wow
that's the epilepsy warning
can you click anything else
that sucks i
apologize but i assume that's my only
available interaction
well now i feel like a jerk
she won for swimming i won a lot of
swimming trophies when i was younger
like a lot a lot i used to do a lot of
swimming
[Music]
she's
an olympian
oh you can jump across things that's
cool
[Music]
i don't know how to answer that oh look
at me go
hmm
[Music]
wait so did i do that like did i send
that text like a ghost in her apartment
or did she
do that
unclear
[Music]
i think i might be a ghost
that's kind of cool
i'm sorry friends i'm not trying to
muddy
maybe i'm her imagination
[Music]
yeah those were imagined
[Music]
i just i really do like it when
games like unpacking kind of a similar
thing really give you a different
approach to storytelling
like it's just through gameplay and you
have to kind of figure it out
like what was the significance of
dragging the radio to the bottom of the
ocean at the start
couch train
boat
work
not sure what that is
carnival
family
[Music]
this is a very
specific
direction i was going to say directing
that's kind of more what i mean than
direction
i mean whoever directed this clearly had
a very specific vision
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
oh i had to drive the sun down
that's cool that's cool that's cool
[Music]
[Music]
i still couldn't tell you exactly what
is happening in the story so far though
we'll figure it out
[Music]
okay we're probably gonna do the things
that the radio
implied
[Music]
it's gonna be a family flashback
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
i wonder if this is like biographic in
some way for somebody
ticket
adult
child
ticket
got there in the end i think
oh
okay
okay you put these in it i guess
here
grab maybe over here
this is very interesting i'm getting
like what remains of edith finch vibe so
obviously that had a bunch of dialogue
we'll say it's a little bit awkward with
the controller
potentially a bit smoother on pc
i believe it is also on pc
super creative like figuring out
what the gameplay is every section
so this is them
running away i would think
[Music]
we didn't need to go that wide i lost
the casa
[Music]
noises are cool
i need to keep hitting it
i guess i do
i'm sure i'm doing it correctly
oh there we go okay
i had to hold on
[Music]
sitting here
[Music]
illuminated love in the dark
[Music]
illuminating
[Music]
that's the same fish
this is them leaving
yeah i guess the idea is like you know
if the story is called a memoir blue
this is her reliving the memories she's
probably still just sitting on the couch
interesting that i haven't actually
played as the um the character role i
had such a mess
looks like i've gone full like 80s by
accident
nope just very messy
[Music]
i'm getting like some kind of um
child of eden vibes
[Music]
i love jellyfish
i went to the osaka aquarium once and
there's a jellyfish room
which is so peaceful
[Music]
fish supposed to be the mom and the
daughter and linda
girl you gonna drown
i haven't seen oxygen in days
it's just too much hair it's just too
much i'm trying to play a video game get
out of my face
i made it worse
[Music]
slightly helped
[Music]
it's like inside
hold this down too i'll pull itself
okay is the part where they get on the
boat
i think
a thousand dollars
damn
i'll say that's my first time again
controlling
the protagonist
um
that's the ballsiest thing i've ever
seen to stand up on the side of a boat
without using your arm to brace
wow
you turn it
yeah
okay
not allowed yet
let's go
[Music]
i love games that do this with no um ui
as well just a custom didn't tell me any
inputs at all
[Music]
controlling the butt
oh let's do a donut
i can't
fish
oh okay it was like what
like combat do i fight them you want me
to kill the fish
no
we do not need to kill the fish
finish that donut
thank you
[Music]
hmm
i'm assuming the tree is a metaphor
i just don't know what for yet
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it'll be like starting a new life
[Music]
i wonder if you leave with the mother of
the father depending on what page you
rip probably not
because i like when the pages were torn
i just picked the one on the right side
because it was close to the casa
um which meant that i
pulled the father away
we get in there
oh
i didn't know i could move them
this is like a new school or something
[Music]
let's get them getting off the boat i
think
[Music]
maybe getting on it
i have to say
[Music]
hmm
i don't have my cursor back yet
[Music]
hmm
maybe the fish
fish
my bad
not exactly what i meant to do
[Music]
strange achievement
of that
uh-huh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
this is super interesting
it's a weird game to like
record video because i feel like i'm
just like experiencing it
i'm not trying to be entertaining
[Music]
this makes me miss my mom
she's coming to visit soon very excited
i want to put it in the box i'm trying
to clean
let me clean
there we go
that was what i was supposed to do
oh it's like it's raining
one of these ones again
this is something i can't do with this
doesn't seem like it
with it once no
all right bye
oh that was it
i see a triangle i hit click
so moving in maybe
i think so i mean it is like unpacking
oh
i'm impressed by the physics
those are terrifying you should
reconsider
yeah this makes me miss
storms
where i'm from is also very stormy
and i swam and my mom was a single
mother for a chunk of my childhood
do you have a sister
man i just like love games like this
you know obviously i'm a person who
favors like a combat heavy video game
would always happen
but this is such a window into people's
creativity in a way that i always really
appreciate it's like i could just you
can really see
the people
and the choices they made behind
a really story-driven indie game like
this like the design choices that went
hand in hand with the narrative is so
meticulous and specific
if you haven't played florence it's a
mobile game you should try it
[Music]
hmm
hmm
back to the carnival
she's very cute
it's like a pikachu or a human
big red cheeks
[Music]
hmm
the first time we've had like a cut like
that i think rather than a transition
fade to black rather than a gameplay
transition
you went to swim school
your shame is what this means
maybe
i did not control any of that with the
record
oh this is that room
just kind of terrifying
this music's beautiful i wonder who
composed
[Music]
[Music]
you
need what i am but i
hide what i am away
i assume it's an original song
[Music]
or the vocalist is rather
[Music]
is it cold
where you are
[Music]
hmm
that's almost too much for me those are
some effects
this is very satisfying
if you're telling me that i could play
again when you just clean stuff uh it
turns out i would enjoy that
this is an aquarium
so her trying to make friends
it's making me sleepy
and sad this is definitely making me
feel very somber
it's not like i thought a game called
a memoir blue would make me
super happy
[Music]
certainly somebody yelling
i just don't know who
why
[Music]
did that happen frustrated works hard
something like that
[Music]
[Music]
i think i can blow this one up
that's a little bit too penny wise for
my liking
oh yeah
gold
and bronze
[Music]
hmm
damn
that happened to me when i was a kid too
[Music]
i'm not sure
where it's coming from
[Music]
hmm
that was cool
very cool
noise too that was very neat
[Music]
okay
packing this up i think
oh she waited and my mom didn't come is
my guess
too much work
yeah
[Music]
kids can really
it's the weirdest thing to say
really be like dogs like
the only thing they want in the world is
your love and approval
and toys
we just don't always have the capacity
to give that to them
something's locked but i don't know what
it is
[Music]
ah
i see
[Music]
this is some like repressed memories
imagery i'm getting here
i'm trying to get rid of the
the branch i promise
it's just hard to grab
[Music]
come here
impressed with the sound design
so
[Music]
not yet okay
now
yeah
so
as somebody who's done a lot of swimming
in their life
standing in front of people in that
outfit would be very weird
[Music]
so
okay
oh i'm having a tension tantrum
i see i see i see yeah let's break stuff
oh we're back at home more breaking
stuff
this is all the stuff from earlier
oh
where are we going
i'm very curious about the significance
of the radio it's obviously been a
repeat thing
we've gone to boarding school
this is so calming
so
[Music]
that was february 2020 apparently
i wonder if this is a true story
yes of course
of course
just what i always suspected
no date on that one
[Applause]
oh
i'm looking around
first time doing that
[Applause]
this is making me miss swimming it's so
weird
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah it really is like an interesting
challenge of just trying to figure out
the mechanics
this one is like gta run just tap a
that was cool i stopped swimming just
see what happened
[Applause]
who took that picture
[Music]
[Applause]
hey she's very good at swimming
[Applause]
she left her mom because
she was absent but i wonder
[Music]
they didn't reconvene or anything
or maybe she's still at the boarding
school
okay this would imply mom has come back
[Music]
nice
[Music]
it's very pretty
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
that subtle sound of the water is
honestly making me so tired it's nuts
okay
oh
[Music]
so
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you come meet us somewhere or
something
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
she looks like a sim
[Music]
yeah it seems like she's saying
something positive why didn't
protagonists take it negatively
[Music]
maybe it's them
much older becoming friends again
maybe they didn't talk for a while
[Music]
that's so sweet
[Music]
oh
[Music]
very sweet little game
even looks like the great barrier reef
it makes me want to look up if it's
australian
[Music]
it's a very sweet game
i really should have turned the
achievements off
damn
is
[Music]
my mom's still around i hope she is
there you go cloisters interactive
it's a really sweet game
i think shelly chen did a fantastic job
i mean they all did realistically
but the direction is very clear
um
very consistent
every single scene
really well thought out
it was a really sweet game
[Music]
i do love having like a
shoulder experience like that every now
and then too sitting here just to digest
a story
[Music]
original song there you go
me human and imogen
[Music]
against the fear that broke
[Music]
why thank you
[Music]
i wouldn't imagine
[Music]
always shout out to the qa team
yeah no bugs
it's really smooth
[Music]
oh i am a bit too i don't know that 47
the ones who gave me the code thank you
47
i know at least five people named in the
credits there
fonts
that's a unity game
you're almost exactly at an hour
57 minutes
it was a very sweet game
yeah it's nice to just get like a
contained story like that it's
definitely i've never
recorded a video of anything like this
before it's very very sweet
i feel like i have some thinking to do
which means it got me
um very big thank you to the team for
giving me a code i hope you enjoyed
watching this it's yeah like i said an
unusual one to do a playthrough often
hopefully if you did like it and you're
in any position to check them out follow
them financially support them in some
way if you watching me play through this
took away from you experiencing it i
would love if you would go do that
that would uh mean a lot to me and also
i assume to them so
thank you for watching i'll see you guys
next time